séquence économique de cette guerre on
en parle avec christophe dans cette
bonjour les états unis veulent mettre
encore plus de pression sur la russie
ils doivent annoncer de nouvelles
sanctions joe biden pourrait notamment
mettre fin à la relation normale avec la
russie aujourd'hui et ce qui
signifierait de réhausser fortement les
tarifs douaniers sur les importations en
provenance de russie ça nous rappelle
évidemment ce cas l'effet trump pour la
chine il devait également promulgué un
important plan daide à l'ukraine un plan
de près de 14 milliards de dollars ce
qui fait en euros environ 12 milliards
et demi d euros votée par le sénat
américain à une écrasante majorité de
l'argent qui doit soutenir l'économie
ukrainienne faut bien se rendre compte
que les trois quarts des entreprises
ukrainiennes
sont arrêtés en ce moment elles sont
arrêtés de fonctionner dans les zones de
guerre c'est une économie qui est à plat
mais l'aide américaine doit aussi servir
à l'achat d'armes elle s'ajoute à celle
à du fonds monétaire international une
aide du fonds monétaire
international a annoncé hier près d'un
milliard et demi à deux dollars pour
répondre aux besoins urgents et le fmi
qui devrait abaisser ses prévisions de
croissance mondiale lors de sa prochaine
réunion de printemps à la mi avril mais
ce envie évidemment en raison de la
guerre en ukraine des sanctions qui
visent
la russie la russie devrait connaître
une profonde récession tout comme
l'ukraine et les pays acp limitrophes à
l'ukraine particulièrement les pays
d'europe de l'est l'europe dans son
ensemble devrait elle aussi subir un
fort ralentissement c'est ce qu'a
expliqué la numéro 2 du fmi au micro de
notre collègue ou d'hier on l'écouté
et puis look est là
j'explose
38,0 cause a fait signer
pour
un
signe de cette crise un chiffre celui de
l'inflation en espagne à des taux plus
hauts de plus depuis 35 ans +7 6% au
mois de février autre signe de cette
crise en allemagne cette fois la
fédération allemande de l'industrie
divise par deux ses prévisions de
production or on sait à quel point à
l'industrie allemande l'économie
allemande est porté par son industrie
troisième signe en grande bretagne le
ministre de l'économie affirme que cette
guerre créé beaucoup d'incertitude
économique des incertitudes économiques
c'est vraiment ce problème que faire
justement pour soutenir les économies
européennes alors la banque centrale
européenne s'est réunie hier elle était
face à un dilemme soit soutenir la
croissance soit lutter contre
l'inflation alors elle fait elle a
finalement choisi de privilégier la
seconde option donc la lutte contre l
inflation ce matin le gouverneur de la
banque de france affirme que l'europe
n'est pas encore face à une situation de
récession néanmoins les états peuvent ou
vont pouvoir soutenir des secteurs de
leur économie feu dépenser plus à
l'industrie par exemple ou bien
l'automobile
la commission européenne dit qu'elle
sera accommodante ce cas et qu'elle
fermera donc les yeux à des excès de
déficit c'est ce qu'a annoncé le
commissaire européen au marché intérieur
thierry breton chez nos confrères de
france info ce matin emmanuel macron lui
plaide pour un nouvel emprunt commun un
nouveau plan de relance mais pour le
moment les européens restent divisés sur
cette question et aucune décision ne
sera prise au sommet de versailles dont
la deuxième journée vient de commencer
il ya quelques instants merci beaucoup
christophe danse est pour votre
décryptage merci